In this lesson we're going to to take
a look at some of the ways that network
speed and other properties affect your
users experience of your web apps.
Networks are not infinitely fast.
It takes time for
traffic to get from here to there and
sometimes it takes way too long.
If you're building or maintaining a web
application you're probably going to
care about this because as
a rule users hate waiting.
Even if you put clever sayings
on the loading screen.
You'd still rather be
watching the course right?
And slowness isn't the only way
the network can get in the way of your
users.
Middle boxes or devices that block or
alter network traffic
such as fire walls.
Can create really puzzling problems
between your users and you.